achat venait nous ne gagnent a fait
entendre sa voix candidate de l'émission
the voice on gagne est aussi yvelinoise
retour sur le parcours d'une chanteuse
pour qui une rencontre a tout déclenché
je faisais du stop et la voiture qui m'a
prise venait de prendre aussi benji en
stop donc on se retrouve tous les deux à
l'arrière et on parle comme ça et me dit
je fais de la guitare et une chez ben
moi j'aime bien chanter d'autres qu'on
devrait essayer de faire la musique
ensemble un jour en ce qui te sens va
essayer et là c'était direct la chimie
et c'était évident
mais il y a cinq ans le duo ningen se
produit régulièrement dans des
restaurants et clubs branchés mais
jamais véritablement sur scène la
participation à l'émission the voice
sonne alors comme une évidence
c'est une bonne exposition c'est
peut-être le moyen justement de
rencontrer les deux d'être opérés par
des maisons de disques détourneurs des
labels c'est ce qu'on cherchait et pour
pouvoir justement passé à la scène c'est
ce qu'on veut avant tout parce qu'on est
prêts on est prêts on a déjà enregistré
deux albums en autoproduction et voilà
qu'on a on est déjà on est tout près que
nous montre juste pas le petit poucet çà
petit poucet peut-être voice justement
la contrepartie de cette propulsion vers
le grand public et que désormais nous
jeunes est seul sur scène qu'en est il
alors du duo c'était une bonne
opportunité une chance comme ça faut pas
faut pas la laisser passer mc pendant un
petit ange passe un petit peu de vent je
deviens il est toujours là il
m'accompagne tout le temps sur les
plateaux et pour moi je le fais pour
nous deux
nous ne gagne réussi l'étape des battles
ou trois membres du jury sont continues
il lui reste maintenant à se confronter
aux votes du public il gagnera tu es la
plus belle voix